-You may know our next guest
from his work on "SNL"
and "Late Night
with Conan O'Brien,"
as the creator of characters
like the Chicago Superfans,
The Ambiguously Gay Duo,
and Triumph
the Insult Comic Dog.
He co-wrote and co-directed
the hit animated movie "Leo,"
which is streaming now
on Netflix. Let's take a look.
-I'm sorry.
-Oh, no, no. Don't be sorry.
Just stop. I can't handle it.
-But my mom says
it's good to cry.
-Not where I come from.
Here. Let me calm you down.
I'll sing you a lullaby,
and you'll go to sleep.
♪ Don't cry ♪
♪ Crying's for weaklings ♪
♪ It's lazy and dumb ♪
♪ Dry those tears ♪
♪ They make you look ugly ♪
♪ Suck it up ♪
♪ You mustn't succumb ♪
-Please welcome back
to the show
our friend Robert Smigel!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-So happy you're here.
-I'm -- It's great to be here.
-That was such a funny clip.
Congratulations.
This is your animated-movie
directing debut.
-This is my animated movie...
Whatever he said.
-All everything I said was true.
-Everything. Not a -- Yes.
And I go, you know --
You know, my history is
with sketch comedy right here
in late-night television.
-Yeah.
-I was, um --
I was the original head writer
of the Conan iteration
of this show.
-Yes, absolutely.
-Back in 19...
Too old. Too old.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I did want
to congratulate you.
Your show is great.
-Thank you. Thank you.
Means a lot coming from you.
-Writing is great.
Eh. I don't know about that.
But...
But, no, thank you.
The writers are great.
And I wanted
to congratulate them
not only on getting
another Emmy nomination,
but also on continuing
the late-night tradition
of losing to the same guy
for many, many years in a row.
-Yeah.
-Way to go.
-Yeah. Thank you. Same guy.
-Same guy. Oh, well, no, we --
It was Jon Stewart when --
-You lost to Jon Stewart.
And I am honored
and flattered to lose
to my friend John Oliver.
-John Oliver.
A great man, but, you know...
[ Laughter ]
No, I don't know. I mean,
it's a lot. It's a lot of years.
It's a lot of years to lose.
And I was thinking --
I was thinking,
is there any way you could maybe
get Trump involved, you know,
so he could go all birther
on John Oliver?
-Oh!
-See what I'm saying?
-Right. 'Cause he's not --
he wasn't born here.
-Yeah.
[as Pres. Trump]
"That's right, folks!
John Oliver has no business
hosting a show!
The 14th Amendment
clearly states
no foreign man...
shall host a late-night program!
When I was president,
I got rid of Greg Ferguson,
folks, the same way."
[Normal voice]
I don't know.
-Very good.
-That's Donald Trump.
Just something to think about.
-It's fun to think about.
-Something to think about.
You've had --
It's sort of a boom time,
not just for you
as a writer or director.
You're also --
A lot of acting roles.
You're actually flying off to
Sundance right now for a film.
-I'm going to Sundance
right after this.
This is so strange.
I'm in a Sundance, like,
competition film.
-That's very exciting.
-Yeah, it is very exciting.
It's called "Between the
Temples" with Jason Schwartzman.
-Yeah.
-What do you play?
-Take a guess.
-Okay. Looks like you are --
You are a rabbi.
Yeah. Okay.
-Very good.
-Thank you.
-I am a rabbi. And now...
But I've been on, like,
four things this year.
This is...
-So, this is "Burying Bubby."
-Short film called
"Burying Bubby."
And what do you think
I'm playing in it?
-Looks like a rabbi again.
-Yes, that's a rabbi. Yeah.
But it's a little bit
of a stretch.
It's -- That was --
That guy is a reformed rabbi.
And the other one,
it's a conservative...
-You got range.
-I definitely have range.
-You were in "What We Do
in the Shadows,"
a fantastic show.
-I love "What We Do
in the Shadows."
It's an amazing show.
-Yeah.
-And there I am with --
This is Nandor.
I love this character.
And I played
Nandor's Jewish friend.
-Okay.
-That's literally --
He calls me Alexander the Jew.
-Okay.
-In the show.
-And then "White House
Plumbers," which is a HBO show.
-It's a prestigious
HBO production.
I'm there with --
That's Justin Theroux.
And Woody Harrelson
is in the scene.
He plays Gordon Liddy
from the Watergate.
And I play a prison inmate
who wants a kosher meal.
[ Laughter ]
-Obviously, one of the voices
you're most known for
is triumph.
-Triumph the Insult Comic Dog.
-Yes.
-Started at
the Conan O'Brien show.
-Started...
And you were recently at the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade.
-Yes.
-So, here, of course,
we know Triumph, and here is --
There was a Leo balloon,
which is very exciting.
That was why you were there.
-They actually made
a balloon for Leo.
And so I'm there --
And, um, I don't know.
I just -- It's the corniest show
left on television. I love it.
-Oh, Macy's Thanksgiving Day
Parade. The best.
-Everybody's lip syncing,
and Hoda Kotb
is reading from a prompter.
The corniest stuff.
And I'm like,
"I got to bring Triumph.
I know I'm here for Leo, but..."
So I bring the puppet,
and I'm with my son.
-So you didn't -- They didn't
ask you to bring Triumph.
You just had it on your hand.
-Yeah. Hoda Kotb --
Hoda Kotb is like,
"What is this show missing?
How about a rubber puppet
to [bleep] on all of us?
That's what we need here."
No.
So I'm, like, having --
I'm taping myself,
you know, mocking the show.
And then the cast of "Shucked"
comes out.
-Yeah.
-A great show.
And they're lip syncing
like every show does.
It's fantastic. And then
this amazing performer --
I think we have a clip.
Alex Newell.
-Yeah. absolutely.
So you notice...
-I notice that she's like
three feet away from me.
So out comes the puppet.
-Yeah.
I love this clip
because we realize
you realize you're on TV
and then you realize that means
Triumph can also be on TV.
Let's take a look.
-Exactly. Yeah.
-♪ I'm independently owned
and operated ♪
♪ And every man that I meet
is just intimidated ♪
[ Laughter ]
-It's like second nature.
-It's second nature.
Triumph just got into it.
He started dancing.
I mean, Triumph
is NBC property,
so I figured
there's no legal issue.
-He is not, however,
CNN property.
And this was, uh -- this was
at a convention years ago.
-Covered the Republican
convention in 2016 for Hulu.
-And there's Jake Tapper,
and behind him we see Triumph.
Now, I will say
he's promoting NBC talent.
-I'm loyal.
-"We love Matt,
Savannah, and Al."
Uh, and then here he is again.
What does that say?
"Positive..."
-"Positively no photobombing."
He's holding up a sign.
Oh.
And then -- Oh, do you have the
clip of my favorite photobomb?
It's from, uh, the 2008 --
Do we have that one?
-Yeah. This is, uh --
This is you and Mr. Met.
Triumph, I should say,
and Mr. Met.
Alright.
-So this is on Fox News.
Go ahead. Roll it.
-Let's take a look.
-Uh, it's on Fox News.
And I realized
that I can hump Mr. Met
behind Greta Van Susteren
on Fox News.
[ Laughter ]
-Anyway, "Leo"
is a heartwarming story
of a lizard who finds
the true meaning of his life
is helping children.
It's for the whole family.
-You also --
There's a Triumph album.
"Come Poop with Me."
Oh, well, yeah. Well --
So I write songs for "Leo."
I wrote a lot of songs for
"Leo." Uh, but this is --
I wrote "Christmastime
for the Jews" on "SNL,"
And, uh, yeah,
"Come Poop with Me"
was, like, the last time I'd
really written a bunch of songs.
Um, you know,
they were quite different.
I think the most popular one
was "Underage Bichon."
-Yeah.
-Anybody? Anybody?
"Underage Bichon"?
It was about...
-Not a lot -- Yeah.
-...a regrettable incident
in Triumph's, uh, young life.
He had sex with a Poodle that
he thought was a year old...
but turned out to be
10 months old.
But he was brave enough
to sing about it.
-[ Laughs ]
-But this is --
You know, it's -- I'm excited
about "Leo" and the songs.
-Is any one Oscar-worthy
on "Leo," do you think?
-Oh, all of them.
-Okay. That's so nice.
-All of them are. But none
of them are going to win.
There's, like, a huge --
I mean, there's like
10 songs from "Barbie."
-That's true.
-That's first in line.
And then -- I don't know
if you heard about this,
but, um, John Oliver
submitted a song.
-Oh, well.
-Yeah. It's not even --
-You've got no chance.
-It's not even in a movie!
-They're just like,
"Right this way, Mr. Oliver."
-You, uh --
One more thing to plug.
You're doing a show
in San Francisco.
-Yes, I'm doing
Triumph's game show called
"Let's Make a Poop."
-Sure.
-Very exciting.
Triumph asks questions --
trivia questions to celebrities,
and they have to answer
with a funny answer.
-That's really good.
-You want to try one?
-Yeah.
-Okay. So I'll do it
in Triumph's voice here.
-Okay.
[as Triumph] "Donald Trump
calls these people hostages,
but they're more commonly
referred to as is."
"Who are Melania and Barron?"
[ Laughter ]
-They're not gonna compete
with Triumph.
[Normal voice] Sunday night
at the Castro Theatre.
-Robert Smigel!
Tickets for "Let's Make a Poop"
are available at
sfsketchfest.com!
"Leo" streaming on Netflix.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."